around a century ago the Spanish flu
killed 700,000 people in this country in
terms of casualty count the that
pandemic was deadlier than both World
Wars plus the wars in Vietnam and Korea
combined the average life expectancy in
this country dropped by 12 years
virtually overnights and many of the
Dead were young people and yet as the
pandemic subsided according to
historians who have extensively
documented this whole episode life
returned to normal in just a couple of
years Society did not reorder itself
there were no permanent changes to say
election law mailin balloting didn't
become the norm clusters of a fet
leftists in San Francisco and Portland
didn't insist on wearing masks for years
afterwards things uh progressed and
people just kind of moved on with their
lives now fast forward a century to the
postco era and as youve probably noticed
the exact opposite happened instead of
moving on elected officials have opted
to indefinitely extend covid policies
wherever possible and some of these
efforts are obvious I just alluded to a
few of them but some of these efforts
are not so obvious in fact they've
gotten basically no major media coverage
whatsoever with few exceptions even
though they could affect your children
in profound ways in particular with CO
as the pretext initially there's now a
large scale effort underway to transform
schools into mini hospitals all for the
benefit of a handful of startups that
are funded out of Silicon Valley now you
thought the point of school was to
provide an education for your child but
that's not the case anymore it hasn't
been the case for a long time really now
the point is to turn students into
patients in order to enrich investors in
California school is now supposedly a
One-Stop shop for all your children's
educational and medical and psychiatric
needs according to research from the
Kaiser Family Foundation prior to co
there were quote essentially zero telea
Health appointments for mental health
and substance related issues you could
look throughout the entire country and
and uh you'd find that it's just not
something that was done but beginning
around March of 2021 everything changed
and that year tella Health technology
exploded in popularity it was used for
um more than one-third of all outpatient
visits for these symptoms and tellah
health then went from something that
basically no one used to something that
more than 33% of patients Nationwide
were participating in and nothing like
that kind of shift has ever happened
before many of these new patients were
students in grades K through 12 and as
the Associated Press reports this week
quote now at least 16 of the 20 largest
US public school districts are offering
online therapy sessions to reach
millions of students in those districts
alone schools have signed provider
contracts worth more than $70
million have you heard about that unless
you read the AP probably not and you
were never asked to vote on that you
were never asked to vote on whether
schools will become also uh places where
therapy is is is uh conducted for 10 of
millions of dollars it just happened
whether you like it or not one of the
largest tele health providers in in
schools today is called Hazel Health
they're active in more than 150 school
districts across 15 states and just this
year the AP reports Hazel signed a $24
million contract with Lo Los Angeles
County to provide teletherapy to more
than a million students Hazel has also
signed lucrative deals in Hawaii Nevada
Florida Texas Washington
Georgia a lot of taxpayer money is being
spent all of a sudden on in school
therapy for kids so that's tens of
millions more dollars spent by the
school system to go along with the
billions that it already wastes but the
bigger issue beyond the cost of all this
is that schools should not be handling
any of this in the first place this is
maybe the most egregious example of
mission creep in modern history like it
should go without saying that schools
are not hospitals and they're certainly
not mental health facilities outside of
dealing with minor injuries which School
nurses can handle and have always been
able to handle schools should not be
offering fullservice Medical Care least
of all psychiatric care they certainly
shouldn't be promoting mental health
treatments via the Internet now this
this is the biggest problem and the
thing we should all be stopping to think
about why are schools spending tens of
millions of dollars to offer therapy to
kids now it used to be like back my day
back in the Dark Ages that the school
guidance counselor was really just like
the school's version of an HR rep for
students so you'd talk to the guidance
counselor if you had some kind of issue
uh with another student or a teacher or
whatever and most of the time she would
give you a sticker or a coloring book
and send you on your way so the guidance
counselor's role was relatively narrow
in that way but now increasingly schools
are taking it upon themselves to play
shrink they're referring to children
children they're referring children to
zoom calls with Anonymous doctors for
talk therapy and parents have no idea
what exactly is being said in these
sessions it's true that parents you know
have to consent to these tah Health
Providers seeing their children to begin
with but beyond that the whole point of
the practice is that parents don't have
to come you know and get their kids
parents can stay at work they can stay
at their job and meanwhile a teleah
health provider is free to say affirm a
child's gender delusions or misdiagnose
a serious
illness now there are a lot of issues
here and one and not even the biggest
one is the quality of care that kids
will receive Time Magazine looked into
this back in November of 2022 and they
reported at the time that quote time
interviewed six mental health
professionals who formerly worked for
tesy or substance treatment startups
some of whom asked to remain anonymous
because they still work in mental health
care regardless of their employer they
had similar complaints appointments were
too short to properly treat and assess
patients CL clinicians were overworked
and policies around prescribing drugs
and treating complex cases often weren't
rigorous enough time also reported that
quote Federal investigators are probing
prescription practices at dun and
cerebral a popular startup that offers
virtual therapy and medication
management for depression anxiety
insomnia ADHD bipolar disorder and
substance use disorders for as little as
$99 per month and that some former
employees have have said overprescribed
stimulants for ADHD in May Pharmacy
Giants including c CVS and Walmart
stopped filling controlled substance
prescriptions from cerebral and dun CL
clinicians now for its part The Wall
Street Journal found that quote dun run
by a former Facebook product manager
with no medical training also advertises
heavily on social media dun's clinicians
continue to prescribe stimulants
sometimes after appointments as short as
minutes so more broadly when when people
go to Tele Health Providers they're
often being misdiagnosed researchers at
the Mayo Clinic looked at around 2400
patients who underwent a video tella
Health consultation followed by an
in-person visit for the same problem and
they found that in 133% of cases the
diagnosis didn't match up so they're
being told one thing from the tella
Health provider and then something
entirely different from the person they
actually saw in person and that might
not seem like a lot 133% and indeed the
mayoo clinic touts this as a positive
number but it's not positive it means
that out of just 2400 people more than
300 of them were
misdiagnosed and that it would seem to
me is obviously a major problem now it's
no secret why these businesses have
appeared out of nowhere and immediately
acquired an enormous amount of
funding part of it is is that it's true
that children and young adults are
experiencing extraordinarily high levels
of mental distress in this country this
year alone more than 60% of teenage
girls reported feeling persistent
feelings of sadness or hopelessness the
director of the cdc's school health
division Kathleen Ethier said that in 30
years of collecting data on depression
among young people quote we've never
seen this kind of devastating consistent
findings when you look at the long-term
data you can see why the CDC is saying
that according to a recent report in
education week CDC data shows that quote
42% of high school students in 2021
reported feeling so sad or hopeless for
at least two consecutive weeks in the
previous year that they stopped engaging
in their usual activities up from
26% in 2009 and those are like shocking
numbers in fact and it means that yes
children are more depressed than they've
been in a long time probably ever and
now they're being treated with a brand
new form of telea Health talk therapy
therapy offered in school even though
there's very little evidence that talk
therapy in general actually accomplishes
anything pure talk as you covered for
holidays with a free Moto g5g phone no
gimmicks and no trading necessary just
sign up for Pure talks unlimited talk
Unlimited Tex and 15 gig data you can
get all this for just $35 and you'll get
the Moto G 5G phone for free but here's
the deal you need to move fast because
these phones are almost gone so if your
current phone is on life support upgrade
for free with pure talk the new Moto g5g
phone B a two-day battery life an
exceptional quad pixel camera and a
whole lot more Pure Talk gives you
America's most Dependable 5G Network at
half the price so make the switch day go
to Pur talk.com Walsh to get this
exclusive offer and select the plan
that's right for your family remember P
talk gives you America's most Dependable
5G Network at half the price so make the
switch today that's Pur talk.com Walsh
to claim your free Moto g5g phone with a
qualifying plan p talk simply smarter
Wireless diversify your savings with
physical precious medals while
stockpiling silver in your home safe
Birch gold group is offering the most
popular special of the year now through
December 22nd for every $5,000 you spend
with Birch gold they'll send you a 1 o
Silver Eagle Coin for free text Walsh to
9898 98 to claim your eligibility now
you can purchase gold and silver and
have it shipped directly to your home or
have Birch gold precious metal
Specialists help you convert an existing
Ira or 401K into a tax sheltered Ira in
gold for no money out of pocket and
they'll send you free silver for every
$5,000 you purchase keep it for yourself
or give something with real value as a
stocking stuffer this year just text the
keyword Walsh to 9898 98 to claim your
eligibility with A+ rating with a Better
Business Bureau and thousands of happy
customers now is the best time to buy
gold from Birch gold text Walls to 998
9898 and claim your eligibility for free
silver on qualified purchases before
December 22nd that's Walsh to 98
9898 just this year the New York Times
reported that a recent meta analysis
found that quote more than half of the
patients receiving therapy for
depression that is talk therapy had
little or no benefit a 2022 uh paper out
of Germany meanwhile determined that
quote after more than half a century of
research and millions of invested funds
the positive impact of therapy and
medication was quote limited now in
other words a lot of people relied on
therapy to fix their problems and
therapy did absolutely nothing for them
in fact especially if they were counting
on this therapy to fix their issues and
it didn't it may have then had the
effect of making their mental problems
even worse so that is the very thin
evidence that supports in-person talk
therapy the evidence supporting Zoom
therapy is even more scanted to the
point where there's really no reason to
think that it helps at all so this is
another area where we are essentially
conducting psychological experiments on
children we're saying hey let's let's
see what happens when we have kids sit
in therapy sessions with some random
person over Zoom maybe it'll help them
maybe it'll screw them up even more
let's find out there's a lot of that
kind of thing going around and across
the country many school districts and
many parents are allowing this to take
place and they're doing it ostensibly
because of this widely reported Mental
Health crisis with our kids but the
problem is that there's there's a lot of
confusion about the cause of this
crisis and usually the problem is blamed
on uh this epidemic of bullying that you
hear about I mentioned the AP article
about the as they put it booming
business of online therapy which schools
are now turning to and spending tens of
millions of dollars on and that article
starts with an anecdote about a young
girl who was bullied in school and
called quot fat and ugly and so she's
now in online therapy with whatever
therapist her school connected her with
the obvious implication is that this is
why we need our schools to increasingly
provide psychiatric care to kids because
you know of all the bullying that goes
on but the thing is that kids have
always been bullied I mean arguably if
you've ever listened to your parents or
your grandparents talk about their
Public School horror stories bullying
used to be considerably worse than it is
these days
and back then kids weren't going to
therapy over it they certainly weren't
going to therapy at school they also
generally weren't psychologically
devastated by The Bullying to the same
degree that kids are today because it's
probably true that kids today are more
anxious more confused more depressed
than they've ever been
before we know that childhood suicide
used to be basically unheard of and now
it's a growing
epidemic so
something is going on here there's a
major problem and the schools have come
up with all kinds of schemes to
allegedly help solve it which now
includes putting millions of kids in
therapy during school
hours but it's not helping and it won't
because the people addressing the Mental
Health crisis with our kids they don't
understand where it comes
from and a lot of
these in fact I would say most of these
therapists and counselors and
psychiatrists who make all this money to
diagnose these problems they also don't
understand the problems they understand
the problems even less than you or I
do and and here's where the problems
come from what lies behind it what lies
behind this Mental Health crisis that
everyone talks about with our kids is a
deliberate effort to psychologically and
spiritually destabilize our children
this is an effort that's been undertaken
in large part by the school system
itself which now pretends that it wants
to solve the problem that it is actively
helping to
create our children are lost they're
untethered they are
vulnerable that's why they're so
incapable of coping with the kinds of
challenges that kids in the past handled
relatively
easily it's because of the conditioning
they've been subjected
to kids are indoctrinated into a
worldview where reality is uncertain
truth doesn't exist their own biological
identity is fluid and subject to to
change their country is evil their
ancestors were bigoted
tradit they're taught to be suspicious
of their own families their own parents
for years they were told to stay inside
not talk to anyone because they might
spread a virus that had a minuscule
chance of causing them any harm
whatsoever if they're white they're
taught to hate their own race if male to
hate their own sex they are severed from
all anchors of meaning and purpose and
then we look around and wonder why
they're all so depressed and then we
send to therapists who invariably will
enforce the indoctrination that put them
in this state of psychological distress
in the first
place although schools aren't even doing
that really they're not bothering to
refer kids to the psychiatrist office
now schools are simply putting iPads in
front of children's faces and connecting
them with Tik Tock nurses who will most
of the time affirm every delusion they
have they're doing this allegedly to
save parents some time I guess but in
reality it's about making a few big Tech
startups a lot of money and it's about
solidifying the indoctrination they're
getting in
school and so far parents are going
along with it in school districts all
over the country they're they're handing
their kids over to zoom shrinks while
they stay at work and all the while
they'll just have to hope that their
children won't get the wrong diagnosis
or receive a prescription for some drug
they don't need or end up with more
mental problems than they already
had we're told this is the future of
medicine and whether you like it or not
whether you consented to it or not it's
probably on its way to your child's
School hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there